[Music]
the first
reaction was thank god that it's paid
off
because it was hard as soon as i come
out of that arena i just broke down in
that back room and had a moment with my
coach to just you know let it out i just
lost the olympic final most americans
have already made up their mind about
how they feel about donald trump about
how they feel about
that particular day i'm not sure what
factual difference it's going to make
we were taught to get down on our knees
and pray to jesus
while they were abusing us there isn't
any known
transmission rates of covert from mum to
baby but in actual fact there are a lot
of babies in
neonatal as a result of their mums
having coverage
welcome to a week in interviews this
week we start in tokyo where team gb got
off to a mesmerizing start at the
olympic games
gold medalist adam peaty became the
first british swimmer to defend an
olympic title with victory in the 100
meters breaststroke
taekwondo has also become the sport to
watch with team gb's
lauren williams narrowly missing out on
gold in her bout
during a nail-biting showdown our sports
correspondent tom parmenter caught up
with the pair
in tokyo the first reaction was
thank god that it's paid off because it
was hard
i'm a championship swimmer i love the
crowd the more people that are in the
sands the better i perform
and i've proven that over the last seven
years i haven't lost 100 meter
in the championships in the last seven
years so
it's been difficult been difficult
racing with no crowd because you you
walk out and you're like
oh my god it's actually like the
gladiator you know in the arena
and i breathe that in and i soak it up
and that emotion just
is extracted but with this there's been
a very different approach into
this olympics because there is no crowd
you know this yes there's a few flags
and yes
there's a few athletes in there but
nothing will match the vibration and the
energy you get from a full
house so yeah i mean in my head
when i went down the mick zone and you
know came out and i had a little bit of
a minute to myself as i wish my family
were here so they could experience this
moment with me
but i guess we're gonna have to wait
until 2024 now so
how long do you keep on winning what's
it when when is it enough
i don't know being a competitive person
i am i don't think it ever is enough
i think sport has a way of telling you
to stop um instead of me choosing when
to stop
if i want to go to paris at least and if
even if you're looking beyond that
you've got to take a long time off and
one thing i've learned
is i think everyone has learned through
covert is how important our mental
health is
at the time i was absolutely devastated
i tried to
put on a brave face and enjoy it and you
know really
walk off that ring with my head held
high but as soon as i come out of that
arena i just broke down in that back
room and
i had a moment with my coach to just you
know let it out i just lost the olympic
final by
a couple of points in a couple of
seconds there's no way you want to lose
an olympic final but
if i lose i'd rather lose by a lot and
you know accept the loss but because it
was so close and it was
i had it it was in my hands for for
until that last 10 seconds or so but
uh on reflection i've woken up this
morning and i've got an olympic medal on
my neck and i couldn't be more proud of
myself to be honest i think
i put in the best performance i could on
the day and i thoroughly enjoyed myself
all day i have no regrets other than
last 10 seconds
and jade jones was there watching you
yeah that was that was
absolutely incredible for me i couldn't
quite believe what was going on
um walking out to that olympic final i
had to glance in the crowd and i saw her
there and
that was such a proud moment for me i
just couldn't quite believe it and i
thought
that was a true like i've made it moment
you know i've watched
jade since i was a kid she's the reason
i'm there and to be walking out to my
own olympic final with jade watching me
was
is the moment i'll never forget and i'll
remember that for the rest of my life
i was truly proud of that moment and
tell me about when you decided
as a young girl that you wanted to
pursue an olympic dream and get to the
very top
yeah so it was 2012 i was in my caravan
watching
the olympics on tally and we were just
flicking through the channels it was
pure accident that we came across
taekwondo but we saw gb
and you know joined the rest of the
nation to back jade and
it was 10 seconds but she was in a
better position than me
we got behind her and saw her take the
gold medal so my dad asked is this
something you want to do
i said no because i'd never seen the
sport before and i did kickboxing at the
time it was fairly similar
um but yeah there was a an opportunity
to
try out for the team and i got selected
i was chosen at the time i was
13 or 14 and i never looked back
now he's the golden boy of the pool tom
dean he won the 200 meters freestyle in
tokyo
with teammate duncan scott taking the
silver joining us now is tom's mom
jackie who's at home in maidenhead
hello g jackie hello good morning so
tell me how you watched it where you
were and how you felt so i wasn't in
tokyo which was a shame
so we had a watch party at home in the
garden
and i had three of tom's other siblings
and lots of family and friends and other
swimmers and neighbors and we did a big
projection in the garden and we
we filmed ourselves doing it and we all
raised a drink to tom and
actually it was really really lovely it
was a really joyous
moment and we um when you look at the
video we
we look like there's about 70 of us and
we look like
mad whirling dervishes just jumping up
and down
and it was very very lovely
i sent him the video from twitter and he
was like
mom i couldn't stop watching it i just
looked at one person and then watched it
again and looked at another and saw
another and he was so thrilled he always
goes very quiet before a race and
i think that's really good so he just
goes into himself and thinks about his
racing so
we tend to keep the chat down but i knew
he was feeling confident you know he
knew he'd put in the work
he knew it was going to be a really
really tight race duncan scott is an
amazing swimmer
there was the russian the romanian
and he knew as he said it was going to
be a dog fight
but i've just said to him now did you
think he could win it and he said yes i
did
and um won it he did by a fingernail so
he's just he feels like he's in a dream
at the moment you know his first
olympics he's only young and he's just
got gold
tom's one of five and they were all
swimmers
and so that's a lot of early mornings
and a lot of after schools and an awful
lot of weekends
racing all over the country and it's a
slog
it's a real slog but you know they put
in the work all i do is provide the
support
and you know tom's just always been one
of those boys
you know from when he was a baby he was
just so positive he always thought that
life was for the taking and if he wanted
to do something he could
you know he wanted to learn to play the
trumpet he would if he wanted to be a
good swimmer he would
and so that positive attitude has just
taken him
all the way to the top and you know good
on him it's been a joy
ross murdoch i'm sharing with you have
you seen the video
what are you on about and he was in he
was welling up he was in tears i gotta
watch this video
he showed me to it he showed it to me
and it just set me off
all over again i was gone again the
emotions kind of took over
all my family all my friends everyone
from maidenhead
all the boys from back home you know it
was it was insane they're all going
absolutely nuts being on the podium in
first place with one of your closest
mates in second place right next to you
for team gb seeing the two union jacks
go up
what more could you possibly want in the
world you know you just couldn't even
write this
and i think the emotions kind of all got
the better of me slightly at that point
um when the anthem was being played and
stuff but it's unreal
two about to cover were brutal not just
for the illness but for the time out the
water the time away from my sport not
being able to exercise and
losing my fitness and everything but you
know you can get through it
um and it's it's not you know the end of
the world and a lot of the athletes are
young athletes out there who
have been able to train you know my
younger brother maidenhead hadn't been
able to train for months and months and
here he is back in the water building
his fitness back up and you know
everyone's in the same boat so
i think just sticking with it and
persevering and having faith in in
regaining your fitness is the best
advice i could give
the success was perhaps even more sweet
for tom daley the diver won his gold at
the fourth time of asking having
previously missed out at beijing
london and rio de janeiro one of the
first calls he made
was to his uh one of his great mates and
former teammate
tonya couch uh understandably that medal
featured pretty prominently
tonya joins me live now from plymouth
where
they both started out uh hi tonya very
good to see you so i've got to ask you
what what did he say in his facetime
call
just that he couldn't believe it he said
he knows that
it was so close but he would never
believe that it actually happened
so he was speechless for the first two
minutes um it was so nice to speak to
him
and he showed me his beautiful wet
meadow yeah well you've been with him i
mean all the step of the way i bet you'd
love to have been in tokyo how did you
react to when you
saw that he'd finally done it i know i
wish i was there in the crowd
but i was at home my alarm was set there
was no snoozing this morning i was
straight up
i was on the edge of my seat i was
jumping i was screaming and then i was
crying so
yeah brilliant to watch him and matty
lee did
super well today yeah it was a lovely
moment and you've known him as i was
saying since he was very young i mean i
think sort of six or seven years old
you've dived with him as well what what
will this mean to him
oh yeah it's been amazing watching him
grow over the years i remember his first
competition
he was just a tiny little boy and now
he's this incredible well-known diver
that
finally got his olympic guild but yeah i
can imagine he got very very teary
thinking about his dad wishing his dad
was there to watch him compete and
and just the emotions of how hard he's
worked for this gold medal
um fantastic it was just beautiful to
watch i can't imagine there was one
dry eye in that crowd no and it's his
fourth olympics
probably maybe you know his last he must
have thought
you know he'd never win olympic gold um
i think that's probably what
he kind of thought at the same time he
wanted it that much so that's why he
carried on
yeah and a quick word on mattie lee i
mean he gets one of his first olympics
i know natalie honestly we cannot forget
how well he done today
his first olympic games standing next to
someone that's
very very well known can you imagine the
pressure he was under today
and the fact he held it together he
should be super super proud of himself
and something tom did say to me actually
he said that
matty lee this year has not been beaten
mercy with pride i'm sure but ready to
talk to us here on sky news matty's
parents
helen and tim who were watching at home
in the early hours of the morning
congratulations how does it feel to be
the mom and dad of an olympic champion
very exciting and very surreal actually
still at the moment it's not really
fully sunk in
just amazing can't believe it i was
going to see the scenes behind you the
bonting am i looking at the remnants of
the party from this morning or just the
beginning
yeah it's the remnants but they're
coming back yeah we're continuing this
party
have you had a chance to speak to matty
yes we spoke to him briefly um about an
hour ago about an hour ago
yeah how's it how's he doing what did he
say is it sunk in yet
i'm not sure actually we didn't ask him
that he just seemed like his normal self
to be fair
just showing off his medal and very
excited
and talking about what he'd been doing
since since the competition
tim what was it like this is matty's
first olympics
and he comes home or he will come home
with a gold
medal is that something he expected was
he that confident
no i'm sure he wouldn't be he's not the
type of person to be that confident i
don't think in the sense of thinking
you're going to come home with a gold no
not at all um
i think he's just wanting to go out
there enjoy the experience
enjoy the whole thing and whatever came
would be a bonus and he knew that we'd
be proud of him whatever the result
and obviously now we're just like like
statically proud i mean
can't believe it so
helen talk to me about his partner tom
daley because
he was actually matty's hero growing up
so it must be a real
pinch me moment for him not only winning
gold but winning gold alongside tom
daley yeah absolutely no there's
there's pictures of him in 2009 um
you know having his photograph taken
with tom daley and sort of getting his
autograph and things so
but to be honest um sort of since matty
moved down to london in 2018
they've become very good friends as well
as syncro partners so i think
and tom's really helped him to to
progress in his diving so we're very
very very happy very pleased yeah
that's an understatement i'm amazed that
you two are so calm i mean
you know i'm feeling giddy and you know
i watched it and i don't even know him
this morning you're probably just
feeling a bit tired now but tim
what next for matty i mean obviously
well hopefully he'll get a little bit of
a rest but
timmy he'll go again won't he this is
just the beginning
he's very much more than sort of geared
up for his diving he's very positive
and this is what well always what he
wanted to do but he's he's now really
enjoying his job enjoying his diving
yeah so he won't want to stop
no definitely not and helen what's the
plan for him when he gets home when you
get your boy home
well a big hug for starters because
we'll be wanting that
but then we'll have some sort of family
and friends celebration
uh maybe maybe sort of next week or
something like that give him a chance to
to recover from the from the jet lag and
things
this is where it all happened gold and
silver medals
in the bmx for team gb what an exciting
spectacle it is to watch these bmx races
the men's race
first that was the first one up with kai
white
tell me what's got into that a lot of
training a lot of training a lot of
sacrifice
from family and mom and dad like they've
obviously slept in cars just to get me
to a race
and that's when i was 13. so imagine
what they do for me to get to the
olympics
if there was no gb team i wouldn't like
to say i'll move my family out i peckham
but
i like for them to be comfy i'd like to
like support them i feel like that
drives drives me more
because being from peckham is not the
best place it's not the worst but it's
certainly not the best the drivers gave
me to make it from
peckham to the gb team in manchester
then from manchester to
olympic team in an olympic team to a
silver medal so
yeah it's just gave me gave me super
drive they've called you the prince of
peckham
i thought that was rodney trotter oh
that name is sticking out that
i'm sticking with that name because yeah
that that just that just rings the bells
you know i mean it just makes sense
after kai had finished his race
he stepped to one side got behind one of
the barriers just close to the finishing
line
and watched the women's race go off and
this included his good friend bethany
schriever
just before i was going up to startup to
do my race i saw that
i was screaming for him i was almost
crying i was like i had to compose
myself because obviously i knew i was
going to see him
but i was so so proud of him like to do
this with him as well is so special
i mean over the past few years i've had
to deal with injuries
obviously funding getting cut and going
my own way
having to work obviously crowdfunding as
well
when they cut the funding could you
quite believe that they did that it was
a very big shock
and yeah it hurt us not just me but hit
quite a few people quite hard
um but i knew that i loved this sport
i think now obviously i'm grateful for
the national lottery for
funding me now and to get the support
because i wouldn't be here now without
all that and without being a full-time
athlete so yeah i'm very very grateful
this week an inquiry published its
findings into the scale of sexual abuse
suffered by children in the care of
lambeth council over several decades
hundreds of children
were subjected to prolonged sexual
physical and racial abuse
one of those children bill maloney spoke
to sky's national correspondent
alex rossi this is
me and this is my brother tony he was
two years younger than me
these photographs were taken on a trip
to hastings
it was supposed to be a happy holiday
but behind
smiles there is darkness and pain
of constant abuse it's caught my whole
life has been messed about with
my whole life by the abuse that happened
it makes you feel worthless it's a
broken heart
it's a broken spirit it's a broken soul
it's broken everything
we were taught to get down on our knees
and pray to jesus while they were
abusing us
and i was probably five or six
but i remember being held on a drain
cover
i had no top on me it was a very hot day
this was in shirley oaks
and one of the carers one of the women
just held me down
on the top of the drain which
burnt me and i was screaming and my dad
weren't allowed to go there
because we've been abused so many times
they didn't want us passing the
information
onto my dad because my dad was a tough
little guy
but i was too ashamed to tell my dad
they killed us
i'm not alive as i should be now i'm
dead because of what they not so much
what they've done to me
but what i've done to my brothers and
sisters
for bill maloney and other children
whose lives have been
permanently damaged the apology from the
council
is just empty words and no inquiry
can ever heal their trauma
i was grabbed beaten tased
all while being called a traitor to my
country for the first time
i was more afraid to work at the capitol
in my entire
deployment to iraq the writers call me
traitor
a disgrace and shouted that i
i an army better than a police officer
should be executed mick mulvaney was a
chief of staff for donald trump who went
on to become northern ireland envoy
before resigning his role
in protest at those capital routes on
january the 6th and he joins us now to
mulvaney thank you so much for joining
us
that was emotional testimony today what
were your thoughts as you were listening
to those offices
this was a very very serious event it's
hard to exaggerate the seriousness of
what happened in this country on january
6th when a group of
people tried to invade our national
capital building
for the sole purpose of preventing the
constitution from being followed because
you resigned
over these rights didn't you i
complained at the time that i thought
the democrats were rushing through
impeachment they didn't have
hardly any uh factual hearings in the
house they didn't call
any witnesses i don't believe in the
senate it was pretty much
a rush to judgment what you're seeing
today should have been
done eight months ago and the simple
fact that's taking place now
i think again speaks to the political
nature and not the fact-finding
objective nature
of the process how are the american
people reacting to this are they
following it is it being watched i'm not
sure what
factual difference it's going to make
most people have made up their minds
there are folks like me
um who was actually in the capital on
that day i would like to know more about
what happened but i think most people
have decided it's midday here the the
olympics are on
it's not a high tv time but generally
speaking i
don't think a lot of folks are paying
attention
expectant moms are being urged to get
vaccinated as well my next guest olivia
buxton
was 38 weeks pregnant when she caught
covered back in january two weeks before
she'd had a checkup and was told
everything was fine but her
levels of amniotic fluid suddenly
dropped prompting her into early labor
i was 38 weeks pregnant when i developed
symptoms of coronavirus um i had
a splitting headache and a cough and
i told rang the hospital immediately and
they basically told me that
i would be fine if i just continued to
monitor it
i then developed really difficult uh
problems in breathing
and i was admitted to hospital why do
you think that mums are anxious about
having
a vaccine while pregnant um i think it's
such an unknown quantity obviously the
vaccine
when you know i was pregnant was
considered not
safe or they hadn't done enough research
into it to actually give it to pregnant
women
so i think it's fine because it's your
decision to obviously have the vaccine
but when you know
it's not just you you are pregnant with
obviously another human being
there isn't any known uh transmission
rates of covered from
from mum to baby but in actual fact
there are a lot of babies in
neonatal as a result of their mums
having coverage
but he is fine now absolutely fine he's
completely healthy he was born
he was due to be born at nine pounds um
but he was seven pounds when he was born
but he is
a very very healthy way and no other
side effects from from me from the
maternal illness